okay well four people joining this
livestream this is one of the hopefully
lost about discussions about database
integration for the next version of
Wolfram language so let's remind
ourselves where we were at last time
what were we still figuring out so so
yes sir yesterday there are two things
that we haven't completely don't think
these are this is the most recent where
are my notes where are my most recent
notes here you see them in 17 last time
yeah okay so so there are there are a
couple things that were still dealing
with yesterday Monday and they were
first the specification for merge Santa
Clause yep okay and and second whether
or not we need to separate take other
than sort by with the next argument okay
okay
okay good I don't think there's gonna
take super long to they don't want to
talk about relations but so it is gonna
take super long okay all right fine
all right let's try to get these ones
taken care of all right so first
question let's do the take a question
first okay
so the issue is given a sort identity
class could we have a third argument to
sort identity class that gives the
number to get from that list correct
yeah I think the answer is we certainly
could but the question is whether people
for discoverability etc will want to say
just peek and the first and things that
come out without without sorting first
without sorting them yeah um okay so
let's see um I mean I would have thought
sampled entity class is but the only
sampling I mean we could do could we do
random sampling no we can't we will
eventually it's it's it's really
complicated to implement efficiently
without without it being order n in the
number of things in the table okay well
but maybe we should have sampled entity
class and by default it can just take
you know so it would be the sampled
entity class of class comma N and one
day and that would always be the the
first elements I don't know this seems
like a very corner case thing I mean
it's well it's not so corner case one
often wants to get I mean okay look is
there going to be
criterion take largest buy or is this
always just the first entries the
question is really that in general if
you if you're just doing limit without
searching first in in SQL you have no
guarantee that you get a say in order
basically I understand I understand by
the way to the sorting from largest to
smallest smallest to largest here so Roy
talked about that last time we talked
about it and we talked about it in LD as
well and the conclusion was that they
were not ready for sort by to support it
and so we should just do rings for
ascending and descending this was a
result of a discussion from no I
understand but why would is that still
something we need to cover in this
meeting yeah we're not gonna put
ascending and descending I don't like it
it's not a good idea right
who where was it being proposed in in
when we had the meeting with LD saying
that sort by was behind or the respect
to what we were doing
yeah we're not going to put ascending
and descending who who is proposing to
put ascending and descending in and
where okay so what they did is what they
said is we're not ready to support it in
full generality in the language so don't
put a symbol there just yet that was the
conclusion so for what symbol for
deciding what the order is in what in
sort by in no in short an empty class
okay so what are you proposing
I don't know we okay did we have a
conclusion or not yeah the conclusion
was use a string for now we're in on the
right hand side of the rule which rule
where you have ordered queue now no no
no no but this is sort identity class
we're talking about yeah and sort by
okay so identity class list of things
population comma
sending or what no publishing ghost was
sending because you can have a different
criterion for each of the things you're
sorting by even for the tiebreakers but
we can't say I mean different design but
that's a different design that we
discussed okay so that's okay I have to
say I'm not a huge fan of this because
having ruled their clashes with the fact
that you can actually sort by a function
and name it so I'm sorry what do you
mean so power function and name it is
that yes attacks you can say something
like if you see sort identity you can
see obviously certain entity class comma
entity function okay and why can't we
have that arrow ascending as well
because we could but what if you want to
mean that entity function and keep it in
the query so we don't get to do that
with rules we don't have a mechanism for
naming an entity function that's a
different we do it's what we do for
entity extend maybe I mean I think it's
kind of convenient that you can annotate
you can extend and see class we'd sort
I mean without know that this is a
different thing right this is an
extended entity class here this is then
a new entity name right a new property
name right don't don't try and fill in
the new syntax here okay the idea that
one can name a function is a so weird
side-effect of sorting
no no not and have it globally apply
elsewhere in the periods it's not a good
idea okay so extended entity class which
is a reasonable thing to do I don't
think we should let's do let's have that
be a separate thing from this okay so
then we can support this make sense I
think okay so I recommend that for now
what would we do so without sorting you
say it makes little sense to say give me
five elements unless it's random on its
okay so it's I think it makes sense
because sometimes you just want to wrap
it around your career because you really
have no idea on my knee there are and so
you don't want to blow up your memory
but the the problem is that if you do
that then it's it's not really going to
be random but it's undefined okay so I
understand completely so I suggest if
we're gonna do that we could call it
sample the entity class and that that
returns that that represents n randomly
chosen elements from that entity class
now if what's inside that is a sorted
entity class then you're all good cuz
they will do the first n yeah because
they'll be the first ten but and in
sampled entity class it is also the
first ten but it's the first ten with
respect to some weird internal keying
that the SQL has done okay so it's
officially undefined so the definition
here would be Gibbs represents a sample
of n elements of the class right okay
now there are two more questions with
respect to the sampling and also first
whether or not we want to support the
skip the first five like take does well
okay so what you're asking for there is
sampled entity class yeah I think we
should I think we should give it a take
yeah but then it's sampled is gonna be a
bit confusing because if it's sample if
people think of samples just like no it
doesn't make sense
listen listen we don't know the ordering
the ordering is not defined right this
is
giant hack okay the whole thing is a
giant hack and this whole business about
paging things that's something we should
support at some point but it isn't
relevant now so put this in if you want
to put in something like that if you
want to elements M through n right and
semen sorted or does this get yes okay
and the other thing that we haven't
resolved last time is I have a very
strong opinion on this whether there
should be an implicit and implicit up
you know because the thing is that this
can be used deep inside another entity
function a sub-query and so it's it's
not going to be very convenient to throw
a message in the middle of all this so I
what do you want to do you want to do an
implicit up to inside sorted I wanna I
wanna I want that both sorted and sample
don't feel if there aren't five elements
I guess it's okay I think this is a
giant hacked our but I guess it's okay
we have to see what happens when it's
actually used this will still be
experimental for now okay okay okay
let's move to merged okay come to entity
class is a new entity class labeled by
chemical names from both of these entity
classes okay so okay so the thing we
haven't covered is the fact that you can
use a rule just like in join cross for
deciding what is the condition to join
on hold on hold on it's gonna take me a
moment to get my brain sped up again on
this thing okay
okay so merged entity class normally
would have
the properties from both class 1 and
class 2 and those properties are
represented as entity property of entity
type , whatever
correct get all just strings well no no
because they might clash right because
the left hand side of the rule actually
it's very convenient especially if
they're named the same on both tables
then you need to specify only one we're
all flying ok so imagine you're trying
you're looking at countries and cities
populations yeah and you want to say
merge on cities they have exactly the
same proposition of their own country so
you could say just population there is
it's gonna mean publishing left and
right otherwise the rule will
disambiguate which one you mean okay so
hold on hold on let me understand this
so what we've got in this case here so
we're saying there's a function of
criterion right a criterion here for
whether they merge so merged entity
class without a function there is it the
case that we want a two argument form
which just merges yeah we can do that in
the case where the anti story defines
relations between what a single relation
between these two classes and that's why
I wanted to get to this before we
discuss relations okay but an
alternative form for this would be can
we have true Amazon or do we have to
have a functional node rompers n would
mean would mean cross join this means
don't filter that's right that's that's
the case that we're talking about the
complete out approach oh so two argument
form would not be a complete it will be
the automatic relation and true one
present we cannot support we need to
have entity function true and tell me
why again
the point is that it's a matter of
referential transparency if you can put
in a pure function then you can put down
values and then no and also we need to
take apart that function figure out
whether all the things that are in that
function complies okay fine
okay um make sure that's in in the
possible issue section of the I mean
probably we want to put that in a bunch
of places because basically we have to
explain to people that entity function
is necessary because it's basically
running on the database absolutely I
mean in non database backed entities we
could in theory or support any function
like if they're running under
yeah well perhaps we can do that do that
but but if the backend is something like
a spark or SQL then it would be
dangerous okay all right so
I do think that if this is running
locally it should just work with with
things other than entity function
but that's something were told to
comment on I guess they've told you here
yes
can you comment on that yet what it
means to use a function there instead of
just happy from trader scopes entity
Franchi alright okay okay well that's a
that's an issue for the future okay okay
all right I'll keep going here so now
what we're saying is I don't understand
what this means what does this mean here
yeses for the merged naming of so when
this comes out you're saying it's going
to be a new synthesized merged entity
class in which
well this is one class one and class two
are the same so for example you can join
person to itself where the property you
joined on is the father for example in
that case you're gonna have a double
where do I see that what I'm joining on
it's the xxx there okay so tell me what
that would be in this case okay so okay
so let's let's write everything from the
beginning so the first sorry if you all
is the first s father no I just want to
call it a last one for now
I mean well okay if you really want okay
let's do this okay father there yep and
then child for the second and the class
are both person whatever and then this
would be this would be something like
[Music]
entity goes to father entity is a
special property that means identity
basically oh what's the next tag or
predates us but but it actually looks
better when you're working with entity
what is this was the father so it means
the the person so the the father
property of the right person so child
has to be equal to the whole and yeah
the left person let's write this out
with a proper entity function form okay
so that is equivalent to if I'm not
mistaken entity function of let's call
it f and C okay and you're saying that
this is
what am I saying the tell me what this
is now this is f equals equals F equals
equals C of father okay
it cuts an ampersand doesn't it oh it's
it's function okay by the way are we
sure that entity function should not
take a pure function in the middle there
that it shouldn't have an ampersand in
the inside itself most of our other go
ahead
nice as the scoping okay okay all right
okay the digression is whatever entity
function with one argument she uses lot
because that would be very many syntax
oh it's just well you're a lot of places
she will do a lot whatever
I mean you eat ice had several times
that before we use slot string we have
to walk over is that badly so what do
you think it I doesn't like that hash
something like hash string works for
things that are not associations it's
mean proposers triple several times but
he doesn't for in this case here so you
say this is compile different because
compiled well to what you're proposing
in this case would be a hash equals
equals how the heck would this work
no that can't work now in this case in
this case advantage of the syntax where
is nice is where you're using an TD
function like for a notation and you
would say just ash age plus ash / -
whatever and so explain explain that
case so that case is one of these when
you're when you're making it an extended
entity class like this
you're saying ash wait / ash yeah yeah
HTTP / - is what you're proposing yep
and so the semantics of that would be
that that is equivalent to hash sub
quotes GDP
correct but but yes but for entities you
wouldn't really be a problem because
they actually are a cessation from
violating the function
I don't think entities are reading
associations but well but this case how
other I mean if I want to understand in
this case this case would be hash GDP
amperes and of am I totally confused
here of
for example and then the association
with all diversities yes well otherwise
known as just oh for goodness sake what
just happened there what is going on is
there some problem here there seems to
be some problem whoops what on earth
this is I mean this is the most recent
version so who knows okay so that's that
case oh my god look at that bug
but no look at this oh that well that's
that's who's doing project management
Here I am
and then oh wow wow I would put it in
our you know what on earth does that say
I would predict that that's a bug in our
4-bit foot for byte 32 bit Unicode
extension there's many things going on
here look look at this this is really
weird why is this giving a syntax error
that's really weird
that is really weird you see that
um something is very very very wrong
here John Folse is the person who should
be contacted maybe somebody knows what
this says um there wasn't I mean what is
this version again because there was a
message that was a absolutely the news
versions from this day because they will
destroy your computer okay okay so
you
please this is Andrea okay so so please
take a screenshot of that show yeah you
probably send this right can you do it
right now should I do it send this right
now - John Foltz okay I'm so actually I
sent a screenshot to Park but I will
send it - okay even if we don't use ash
of GDP and we just use this index that
you wrote there with with the strings
that will also be IND shortcut that he
uses lot and then your grandparents
sometimes yes I agree but but I'm asking
the question does this work
muskan no of course it doesn't I mean
and the only reason why it's not working
is because you use hash GDP instead of
hash of GDP no I understand that but
yeah I don't completely understand maybe
we can bring this up in an LCCC meeting
yeah eat I was very very open about this
well he might be right
okay so anyway let's keep going here so
so what you're describing is in the case
of the merged entity costs you are
saying
okay so this here
oh boy
you
this is saying yeah I mean I understand
what it's saying it's really hard to
understand that that's representing the
second of these things so explain to me
if I want to do it the other way round
you said then give the arguments to
merge the entity class than the other
order okay if you want to do it the
other way around then you would do
something like then you would get the
property let's say child or father we
know I could see that right but I mean
why wouldn't this be the right merged
entity class emerging as in
that seems like okay oh that syntax were
just where you have just father yeah
means take father and left and right and
this is what them to what Joyner crossed
us okay hold on hold on hold on
so that case then is equivalent to
that's equivalent to so of of F comma C
F of Father equals equals C of father is
that correct yeah
so you get siblings or half siblings
okay okay okay so okay so this is saying
right so these this is the case
I'm very confused here okay so what
you're trying to do what is the role of
this this thing here that's just a name
but then I'm sorry what does the final
thing come out us how is this name so
this is basically okay so the problem is
that in this case you're doing a self
join and so you would have some kind of
key collision function on all the keys
because the properties are the same but
the beauty of of entities or actually
and properties is that you you can put
if you have a first argument of the
entity property if you needs to
disambiguate and so and so in this way
this merged entity class will have twice
as many properties as person and they
will be basically realized with the
other end child and so you can always
access them all and what is the name of
one of them I mean so so let's say age
is one of the things so what is a so
that would be empty property
um father goes to person comma age
what why don't you go with your father
boost this entity Robert your father
no no we don't want to do we don't want
to lose the original information that
comes coming from from from person okay
so you're saying the alias name arrow
the original type name comma and then
age so Tolia and the advantage of that
is that if you do it this way then you
don't lose person and then you can still
label it you can it can also Tony Tony I
mean this is now a an extended entity
property somehow this is a new form of
entity property if I'm not mistaken yes
have you seen this before and implement
it
yes I saw so this is basically one of
the ways we came up with distinguishing
between the types that come out of join
outward plus we don't have any other
use for this because that way in general
you know in in the type system like for
the compiler that's a function that
takes an input and return something
wait a second what does this have
anything to do with this because these
are type specifications person is a type
yeah okay well well I mean there is
another case and these properties the
first target is robbery is not exactly a
type we have another case which is much
simpler when you extend an entity an
entity class then you you you get extra
properties yes what is the type of those
properties that's a good question let's
look at that let's look at that case ok
so we've now got an extended entity
class here and I thought it's just I
mean I see I see so if I were to ask for
what is the full form of density is it
entity so density it will be entity
property of that's a good question enter
the property of oh I thought I would
think it's this rather grotesque thing
it's entity property of this comma
density but that's the name of that is
that you can now use this entry property
even on an entity that didn't have this
annotation and we don't support it yet
but we could okay so what's your point
so then in the cases that you can apply
this we tally just the bare Italy and
you don't know how itself well that's
interesting but okay so what's the
analogy to between that and the merged
case
okay so down here you are proposing this
wacky thing because this is something
different yeah actually I am proposing
this in general I mean I don't see why
should we support it just for it but
what are you proposing and in the case
of how would that relate to an extended
entity class I mean what I'm saying is
that whatever construct you're using
before whatever reason you use a rule
goes for string then you're effectively
renaming that thing in place no no no no
no no no no I mean not not beyond that
actual construct itself no you cannot do
that of some kind I'm not beyond
absolutely not be honest wouldn't be a
side effect but if you have a rather
grotesque big expression then you could
alias it with the rule and then the
shorter form of the of the ket it
doesn't get used very far because only
things within a scope of that I don't
what I'm saying is that imagine you're
doing you're doing descent is extended
entity class blah blah blah now you you
want to rename this extended entity
class to something like extended and
then you can use entity property of just
extended
somewhere could use entity property
where because you can't use it out of
the scope of that rename yeah an entity
value when the first argument is that
okay hold on so so what you're saying is
I'm sorry I just honest and how you can
it's in the same way as is the join as
with the entity extent where we are wait
a second wait wait what do you got there
not there okay you're proposing in here
where do you put it in here okay let's
let's make it okay you imagine you have
entity value
okay and then you have something like I
don't know let's say sample dancing
class then X goes to this is not
convincing me okay go on now you have a
huge query
I give me just a simple query let's do
this query here put that okay then you
have comma 10 I guess for simple entry
class and now all you want to say entity
property no look at this look at it it's
not scoped incorrectly I see what you're
gonna do but it's wrong
okay now go go and say what you want to
say X bestie X arrow dancer no X comma
this I'm not married to this I think it
might be convenient in some cases but
see my objection my objection I would I
just do this here my objection is this
is not even in the subtree yes right
it's only scoped by the fact that it's
in the same entity value yeah but that's
the keys in general French Dip Robert I
know but it's not right to do that
scoping you can't go up and down right
so if you have a function right and you
say function X the X is scoped in that
body right it's not scoped if I said
plus X here the X is not scoped outside
of that body but still this is different
from scoping because we're the same
logic we should say that we can't use
extended properties outside of the place
where we extend in them but that's not
true
in my district but wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait hold on
and how far out can we use them so oh
gosh so wait a minute where this
extended entity class appear so I
thought I don't understand this I don't
understand okay
okay the way extended entity class works
is that when whatever surrounds extended
entity class will now see density
whatever surrounds it well now if you
want to filter by dances later you can
yes you can so so in this case basically
the scoping is reversed with respect
function that's why we don't call it
scoping this is yet a different thing
it's conceptually the same except in
that in that case that was a single
property but in this case we are adding
an alias to a type
someone on our livestream comments that
this functionality seems quite
complicated for the average user you
don't say yeah no I hate to be fair it
always sounds this bad woman in the
middle of designing something the goal
is to make it not sound this bad and to
make it easy to explain and simple but
it gets it's it will be complicated
until it's simple um
whole functionality is intended for
fairly expert users um it's intended for
people who are dealing with large-scale
data that has not been I mean I guess
that
the most common case here will probably
be that there is
I mean I would think when this is
backing datasets people will be able to
use dataset queries
that compiled into the stuff
automatically is that right yes but I
have to tell you see well first of all
not to this stuff it will be probably
compiled to something lower level on
this we have an intermediate layer for
that but secondly if you try to combine
dataset queries with sub queries and
with any complicated structure like here
they will also not look that Pleasant
like if you try to add certain new
properties to dataset you know to do
other things and on top of that they
will quickly become also pretty involved
do you have any idea of how complicated
it is to write this indirectly in SQL
like we already doing pretty advanced
stuff yeah I understand gets translated
into five different possible backends
and there are different dialects
well the question is what does the SQL
query look like and it often looks quite
grotesque
without true statement that depends on
who is viewing that if for a scale
expert it definitely not for people not
familiar with SQL everything would look
girls desk I think yeah but but this is
not exactly your ab you know the most
simple thing okay but any case okay drop
this aliasing thing for now I don't
think it's a core fine let's talk I mean
it's all important for for let's drop it
okay um I wanted to mention something
while talking about the extended entity
class you know especially about the name
because now that we've seen all the
other class like constructs the extended
entity class is a little bit off because
it doesn't really have to do anything
this entity classes what it does but
instead it adds a property and it could
add a property to an entity to a single
entity or to a collection of entities
it's not really class related I don't
think it should work on a single entity
but along with this is entity classes I
don't know I think this is not a
terrible name but Tony do you have a
better suggestion
I like the entity extent of course it
gave to suggesting that it is in the
context of entities no I did say ending
an entity class I'm sorry what are you
suggesting the previous name that we
considered was entity extent no no we
went through this no verbs or extended
entity because it's actually adding the
property to each entity it's not
important that the thing is a class it
was important because you can't add this
property to a single entity in a class
and not add it to others
I don't think that statement is right
it's more about if you were to add the
property to one entity and not to
another then you can't combine them the
two resulting things that's that's the
true statement but I personally I mean
right now don't have a problem with
extended entity class even if as a
courtesy we allow a single entity there
pickets consistent with all this other
stuff aggregated entity classes etc etc
etc
okay I probably can put it in a
different way an operation of extending
a single entity irrespective of the
others other entities in the class is a
different operation okay all right fine
can we go on let's go on for now okay
let's talk about merged entity class so
we're still this is the morass of third
arguments of this thing okay so this
alias is a completely different alias
from the one you were just trying to
talk about right yes okay good
and that alias has to do with what the
name okay so in the merged entity class
the name of the entity property that
appears there is this rather bizarre
name is that correct yes I think that as
a courtesy we can allow only the first
few conflicts well okay but but but Tony
that is a new form for an entity type
and an entity property correct and the
point I was making is okay so it's
essentially an annotated version
oh boy
I mean it's fundamentally the same as
posts and comma age
why does it care but first this arises
when we combine two types we didn't have
that problem before that we could
introduce two types that clash but with
the merged entity class we have that
problem so we need to only want itself
merging right what is merging when it
happens to be well you know like
population might happen to conflict
between country and city
is not a problem because there you have
a country and city to disambiguate which
population you're talking about I see
okay so this is purely a problem
you
okay with self merging
yes so I think a good example would be
you want to do some computation with
respect to the neighboring countries or
country like you want to take all the
countries that are have larger
population than all its neighbors huh
then you would first merge and then
filter when you filter you need to be
precise about what entry priorities you
want this is a very weird corner case it
seems wrong to use such a big syntax for
it
let's think about how else we could
represent this okay so why don't you
write down an example of trying to
filter on emerged one okay so let's try
by mean let's just do an age-based one
for parent and child okay that's well no
let's let's see it let's see how it
works okay so all children of parents
over the age of sixty or something
okay how would we do that so it's the
merged entity car we do that you don't
need it you need it only when you are
comparing I'd say all children with even
age and parents like a older than 60
well why do I say all children younger
than 10 and parents older than 60 okay
okay so let's write down or you can say
something like the difference in age
being parent-child is fine let's do
difference in age okay let's do that
okay so how do we do that here so you
would say father goes to person
when are we let's be specific person
is what in reality the type or class
doing what is reality no no I'm saying
this
what would we actually type so this is
oh you can type person capital P we are
building yeah okay fine
but this is applying itself to a
data set to a database
in which that is a label of some column
is that right it's a label of a table
okay
hey this point has no meaning this is
just an arbitrary alias that we're
introducing right yes so we call it
alias one okay okay now the second you
don't reason why this if you don't want
I'm going to because I want to
understand what's going on here
okay and then what and then entity ghost
father no no I mean that's your crazy
thing no can we light it out properly
please well this thing here right here
okay yeah and change father to air this
one no why no that's wrong yeah now
around this you could filter density
goes around the whole thing yeah yes of
entity function now you have only one
which can call M comma M of entry
property and yes one ghost person come
age
yeah I get divided by is less than
whatever it is you know it's the
corresponding thing with alias to let
sides yeah okay so the issue is we're
referring to now I mean we could do this
more layers down is that right so we
were referring to something in this
merged entity class
yeah yeah like person itself could be an
arbitrary come to quit being a self
emerged what could be itself emerged
entity class like you want to do it with
grandchildren okay so the what happens
if there's conflicts in the aliases
between different layers we've we can
feel even before executing it
the only problematic case Steven is if
there are conflicts between Alice's on
the same layer because we are comparing
basically a whole succession of segments
not just single one so if there is Elias
one somewhere deeper inside in the
second query that's not a problem
yeah okay so Tony do you see any other
mechanism I mean in your I mean to me
this using up the syntax for this rather
obscure case
well I don't have a better idea I try to
come up with some but no Colin wake up
you need all this came up with a
counterexample soul oh there is there is
another way we would do it but that
would require adding a different add
that alias thanks class but then we
would have to support it in general also
still one I want to mention that from
the existing OMS they all basically
stumbled upon this problem and no one
solved it so it's not an easy problem
Robbie you're proposing a solution here
yes okay so the only ORM it solved it
then is this as well from from from the
ones I'm familiar with yes and the
problem to be specific is the nesting of
of aliases because we keep this symbolic
chain of errors and that allows us to
create arbitrary levels
and so that was one of the biggest
reasons I think why other m's don't
expose explicit joints and those which
do they don't have a mechanism to
actually resolve conflicting fields
still okay all right well fair enough
okay fine let's say we do this now
what are your various short forms for
the third argument of merged entity
class okay so it's the same as what is
documented for down across so you can
have a single app property rule a list
of property or or a list of a little bit
to join across
you
you
okay so join across
okay
and we have the advantage over them that
we can do automatic so let's keep the
the third argument in some cases okay so
this is so but but your entity thing is
is some kind of bizarre funkiness
because that's not supported here right
what no no the case where instead of key
a right
you mean the whole gulp entity yeah
because because entities I mean because
these associations cannot have a whole
association inside what Stephen in some
sense when you say entity is just a
short kind of saying that we are
comparing the our canonical names
actually right but I think what one
wants I don't think it's right to use
that I don't think it's right I think we
want some symbol or something else there
okay that would be better I actually
support you already I think so
this automatic arrow property I wish we
didn't have an echo by the way here
means the whole entity the whole LHS
entity
is the same as the value of property yes
the RHS now what about if I want to do
some comparator like greater than so
then I have to but this is simply a
short form these are short forms for
equality yes these are called echo
joints in SQL we might want a
documentation I guess as a and then
there is also so the case where you drop
the third argument or go ahead the case
where you drop the third argument it's
called natural join okay well hold on a
second
so this is short forms otherwise known
as equi-join sounds very very much like
something related to horses
sorry um okay so quotes natural joins
whatever that means okay so this is
covered all the cases you wanted to
cover for weird third arguments correct
yes okay all right natural joins okay in
the keys where there is only one
relation between two tables two types
that means that there is only one
property that has the value of that and
it's a keen one or the other there's
only one sorry so this is the case where
it's class one and class two and there's
only one overlapping thing we now are
not overlapping it means so imagine like
take CT CT has only one country property
yes now I don't know if country is only
one city property sits valued property
not city named property so you you
compare the types of the entity valued
properties yes there is only one
matching between the two then yes and
then what do you do
and any emerge over that but that's not
enough it also needs to be kind of
registered like that so that it's not
due to arbitrary types which have these
things but they are really connected in
the database that's that's our problem I
mean general the thing that we should
grandfathering for built-in entities is
that you know you have to take two types
and each one of them has only one
property that is of the type it's
actually a bit stricter for that there
surely be actually one link because it
could be that those two links are not
the same so there is only one property
that he has a value that is an entity of
the earth yeah that's why I said they
are kind of connected together more
strongly than just that
you
but in any case Steven this is one of
the shortcuts which is convenient in
practice but which still of course is
just a shortcut for the full form with
energy function okay sorry what is it
again
okay so what I was saying is that you
have a type 1 and type 2 and you know
that there is only one property of type
1 that is an entity of the type tool ok
so in this case you you can you have a
natural way of joy okay I'm sorry
structured by something else um it
sounds like you have this under control
is there anything else we need to go
over II I mean if you need to go to
something else fine but there was
another thing what it's it's it's long
so I'm not gonna get it right now but
what roughly is it okay now the question
is at the at the entity store mm-hmm so
relations get registered there and now
that we understand how merge works we
can look at those and see if they make
sense to you no I'm sorry say that again
when you define the entity store the
relations get registered along with the
other properties okay so entity store
has an existing way of dealing with
relations yes
okay no no no not now not not now in the
in our formatting that you are looking
at the notebook from two to three so
there's a new definition of entity store
that you have introduced well we have a
different second argument because it
contains the connection to the SQL
object yes I understand
okay I gotta go I gotta go sorry okay
okay see you guys soon